foreign
[Music]
for our daily cancellation we turn to
American Idol most interesting thing
about this show is that it is apparently
still on the air I don't know if it's
indicate if it's an indication that I'm
out of touch or that American Idol is
irrelevant but until this moment I
thought American Idol was canceled years
ago I suppose that's a false choice
however I mean the answer
could be and probably is both I'm out of
touch and the show is irrelevant be that
as it may um it was back in the cultural
conversation ever so briefly this week
but not for anything related to music or
singing instead it was the story of one
contestant and more specifically a
judge's reaction to that story
that had people talking watch
in May 2018
um a gunman walked into my school
uh
I was in art room one
he shot up art room two
before he made his way to art room one
uh lost a lot of friends
eight students were killed uh two
teachers were killed
and uh it's just really been Negative
Man Santa fe's had a bad rap here since
2018.
what you doing Katie our
facts
okay you should be singing here because
you love music
it's true
go through them
I agree
you didn't have to lose eight friends
I hope that you remind people no we have
to change because you know what I'm
scared too
it's terrible Katie it's horrible
[Music]
now before we deal with the substance of
Katy Perry's response to the extent that
it had any substance we cannot ignore
the incredible narcissism on display
here by her
Perry has apparently attended the you
know the same training seminars
alongside Gisele fetterman to learn how
to make other people's traumas about
yourself
he is calmly recounting his own horrific
experience and Perry used it as a
platform to put this put on this
over-the-top emotional performance
she even relates it back to herself
somehow
I'm scared too she says as her fellow
judges comfort her they start patting
her on the back and comforting her while
the kid who was actually in the shooting
stands there and watches
here's a hint if someone is telling you
about something awful that happened to
them
your response should not contain the
words I or me unless you're saying
something like I'm so sorry or I'm here
for you
but if you're attempting to put yourself
at the center of this person's suffering
or deflect from it so the focus is on
you and your own emotions
then you are a classic narcissist
and maybe worst of all you're creating
an incredibly awkward situation for
everyone else who has to be in the room
with your lack of self-awareness
I can only imagine how comfortable it
must have been for that young man to be
standing there not sure what to say or
how to respond as Katy Perry launches
into her camera ready monologue like
she's auditioning for a soap opera a
monologue that was planned by the way
considering that the judges would have
known ahead of time that a contestant
was coming up who'd been in a mass
shooting
that fact was certainly conveyed to Katy
Perry and her cohorts by The Producers
before the kid got up on the stage she
didn't she didn't you know burst into
tears spontaneously she had all this
planned in her head ahead of time and I
understand that this is a very cynical
interpretation of events but I've been
around long enough and I've been in
media long enough and I've met enough of
these sorts of people to justify my
cynicism
but what about the actual point she was
making in her scripted diatribe she says
that the country has failed the victims
and survivors of this school shooting
and of course you mean specifically that
it failed by not passing enough gun
control laws to prevent the shooting
from happening never mind that the
shooter already broke a dozen different
laws in carrying out his crime it's
unclear how exactly it would have helped
to add one or two more laws onto the
pile that the killer was already
determined to disregard
you can only make and act illegal so
many times before the laws start to
become redundant and therefore useless
yeah this is what we so often do in our
culture when a bad thing happens we
declare that the bad thing is the result
of some sort of failure
it's always a systemic failure failure
of government of policy
people like Katy Perry take solace in
the idea that all tragedies are policy
failures because and really all bad
things you know they say poverty is a
policy failure too
because for one thing it gives them an
excuse to push their political agenda
obviously but for another it Comforts
them to think that the right policies if
we could finally land on them would
banish all the bad things from our midst
when Perry says that the country failed
because there was a school shooting what
she means is that we ought to have a
country where there are no shootings at
all
and she's right in the sense that every
mass shooting and every bad thing
shouldn't happen that's why it's a very
bad thing if there's something that's
evil like any evil shouldn't happen
but Perry like any other leftist
believes that a country without any
murder without any bad people doing bad
things is actually practically
achievable and that it can be achieved
through policy
the irony of course is that the
utopianists who imagined that a world of
perfect peace and Harmony can really be
achieved 10 through their policies to
create a world that is ever farther away
from peace and harmony
worlds like uh the world of Chicago for
example
people people with uh with with Katy
Perry's worldview run most of our major
American cities and most of our major
American cities are violent crime and
disease-ridden hellholes which actually
isn't all that ironic when you realize
that effective governance means
understanding human nature and
understanding human nature means
acknowledging that bad people will
always exist and they will always do bad
things you can do a lot you can do a
much better job of containing and
mitigating the damage
but you can only do that once you've
acknowledged the Fallen state of man and
that although you can mitigate the
damage and try to contain it
there will always be damage to mitigate
and contain
with all that said
it's still true that a school shooting
represents a failure in fact it's a
whole series of failures
but they're mostly the kinds of failures
that Katy Perry and her ilk never want
to talk about
first of all it's a moral failure of the
person who carries out the deed people
have agency they have free will they
choose to do things
they should be the first people we blame
for the things that they choose to do
rather than pinning it on the country
um
and also very often there have been
parenting failures that help to produce
the sorts of people who would do
something like that
and failures in a culture which breeds
people who have no meaning no purpose in
their lives seemingly no capacity for
empathy or or love
these are all failures
and they're the kinds of failures we
skip over focusing instead on debates
over gun control
and that itself is also a failure
one which only ensures that this kind of
thing will keep happening with the same
or greater frequency
and that is why Katy Perry is today
finally cancer
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]